I hope it I hope it comes out intensely
that's not to say that it's about me
that I think that you know conducting is
obviously a visual activity because it's
about showing things with your gesture
to the musicians but I don't want the
audience to feel that they have to see a
show for me in order to to feel how
exciting the music is but on the other
hand if the music is exciting and if I
look unengaged and not not in it then
that would certainly prevent the
experience from being what it really
should be so it's a fine line that you
have to sort of walk to to really infuse
the performance and the music with your
deeply committed personality while
allowing the music to still be paramount
it's a it's a tricky thing and that's
what we're all all going for
absolutely I mean I you know you have to
allow your face to show the show the
character of the music but that's not
something that I plan you know it's like
you don't say okay well I want them to
think I'm happy so I'll smile now you
naturally allow yourself to feel the
music and then just as you know when
you're hanging out you know sometimes
your face looks more serious sometimes
what's more animated sometimes it looks
more pensive you know that's definitely
part of the communication
it happens right away actually or
hopefully it does if it doesn't then
there's probably something wrong it's
interesting you can you can you can
really understand the difference in
orchestra feels and conductors if you go
to a conducting class where there may be
six or ten or twelve conductors in a
very short span of time often it happens
that these conductors will be doing the
same music so you have a really good
basis of comparison the sound is
literally different within one second of
or instantly once a new conductor comes
on they'll conduct the same music that
had just been done by another conductor
the oyster sounds completely different
it's uncanny there's something in the
body language that immediately
translates into sound and it's one of
the exciting and kind of amazing things
about connecting